From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. I was little, maybe six or seven, bedtime. I was deploying my best delay tactics. I needed water, then a Band-Aid. I think I had a lot of other demands, too, that I don't remember.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。当时我很小，大概六七岁，正值就寝时间。我使出了浑身解数来拖延睡觉。我需要喝水，然后又要创可贴。我想我当时还提了很多其他要求，但我都不记得了。
And then, this part is vivid. I remember I asked my mom, how do you have the answers for everything. She was on her way out the door. She said, oh, I don't have the answers to everything.
然后，这一段记忆犹新。我记得我问我妈，你怎么什么都知道。她当时正准备出门。她说，哦，我并不是什么都知道。
I stayed up for hours. It was a deeply unsettling thought. I hadn't remembered that moment in a long time, but working on the stories in today's episode, I kept being reminded of it. All kids eventually learn that the adults in their lives don't have the answers to everything. Right? I think so. I ran this by the ones I have on hand at home.
我失眠了几个小时。这是一个让人极其不安的想法。我已经很久没想起那一刻了，但在制作今天这一期的故事时，我不断地想起它。所有的孩子最终都会发现，他们生命中的成年人并不是万事通，对吧？我想是的。我在家里找了几个现成的人试探了一下。
Do you remember a time where I did something or said something where you were like, oh, you're just a person, you don't know everything?
你记得有那么一次，我做了什么或说了什么，让你觉得，哦，你只是个普通人，你并不能掌握一切？
No, I never had that epiphany, because I never believed that you guys knew everything or were perfect. Like, ever. Like, straight out of the womb, I was like, these are flawed people right here.
不，我从来没那种顿悟，因为我从来没觉得你们无所不知或者完美无缺。从来没有。就好像我刚从肚子里出来时，我就觉得，这几个人全是瑕疵品。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
This is Jacob. He's 12. Can you tell? He was not going to bite.
这是Jacob。他12岁。看得出来吗？他可不会嘴下留情。
Yeah, I mean, I guess it was really surprising to me when I found out that you used to smoke. I was like-- that was like, that doesn't really sound like you. Like, even though, as a baby, I knew you were a flawed person, I just didn't expect that from you.
是啊，我的意思是，当我发现你以前抽过烟时，我真的很惊讶。我就觉得……那听起来真不像你。尽管作为一个婴儿时我就知道你有瑕疵，但我确实没想到你会那样。
You did not know I was a flawed person as a baby. [LAUGHS] You depended on me for everything.
你当婴儿的时候可不知道我有瑕疵。[笑声] 你那时事事都依赖我。
Even as I was, like, being formed in your belly, I was like, this is a flawed belly.
就算我还在你肚子里成型的时候，我就在想，这肚子肯定有瑕疵。
[LAUGHS] Get out of here. You're excused. Go get your brother.
[笑声] 去你的。你可以走了。去把你弟弟叫来。
Jacob's brother is still little enough that he hasn't started trolling me yet. Micah-- he's 10. I told him about the moment I first understood my mom didn't know everything.
Jacob的弟弟还太小，还没开始捉弄我。Micah——他10岁。我告诉了他关于我第一次意识到我妈并非无所不知的那个时刻。
And I'm wondering, are there any moments like that, that you can remember?
我想知道，你是否记得类似的时刻？
Definitely.
当然记得。
No hesitation there. Micah can remember when it happened-- specific moments, like this one from when he was six or seven years old.
他回答得毫不犹豫。Micah记得那是什么时候发生的——一些具体的时刻，比如他六七岁时的这一段。
Yeah. At one point, I had a nightmare, and I came to my parents' room to--
嗯。有一次，我做了个噩梦，我走到我父母房间去——
Me.
我这儿。
Yeah, your room.
对，你的房间。
You can talk to me. [LAUGHS]
你可以跟我说话。[笑声]
OK, great. So I walk into this room, and I'm just like-- see the lights are off, and then I wake up my-- I try to wake up my dad. And I'm like hey, hey. I keep saying, hey, hey, hey! He's not responding.
好的，太棒了。所以我走进这间房，然后我就像——看到灯是关着的，然后我叫醒我……我试着叫醒我爸爸。我喊，嘿，嘿。我一直喊，嘿，嘿，嘿！他没反应。
So I have to shake him. And then he wakes up, and he goes like-- [GASPS] he jumps. And he's just like-- he, like-- and it just, like, makes me think, like, are you scared that something's going to happen as well?
所以我不得不摇晃他。然后他醒了，他发出……[倒吸一口气]，他跳了起来。他就像……这让我想到，你是怕发生什么事吗？
Oh, because he was scared.
哦，因为他当时害怕了。
Yeah. And also, if it takes that much to actually wake you up, then that also sort of scares me.
对。而且，如果叫醒你要费那么大劲，那也会让我有点害怕。
Why?
为什么？
Because if I'm like, something happens, and I'm stuck in my room or whatever and I'm not-- and I can't come over here, whatever, if I yell for you, you guys aren't going to answer. And that's hard for me. And then, I'm just like, what if like something actually happened.
因为如果真的发生了什么事，而我被困在房间里或者别的什么情况，我没法跑过来，无论怎样，如果我大声叫你们，你们没反应，那对我来说太难了。然后我就会想，万一真的出事了怎么办。
It's not just that we might not answer if he yells, or jump up if he comes into the room. It's also, he feels like, shouldn't we already know what's going wrong while we're sleeping. That's a real question, Micah had.
这不仅在于如果他大叫时我们可能听不见，或者如果他冲进房间时我们可能惊跳起来。这还在于，他觉得，难道我们在睡觉时就不该察觉到有什么不对劲吗？这是一个真实的问题，Micah曾有过。
Yeah. Or if I'm somewhere else and he knows that something's happening and he'll fly through the window. And, like, if I was in school or whatever and something happened, and he would just be at work, typing, whatever, and he'd be like, oh, I sense something in the force. And then he just, like, flies through the window and enters the school, and he just picks me up.
是的。或者如果我在别的地方，他知道出事了，他会飞奔过来。比如我在学校什么的，如果出事了，而他正在上班打字什么的，他会想，哦，我感知到了原力。然后他直接飞过窗户冲进学校，把我接走。
Did you really think that?
你真的那么想过？
That's exaggeration, but something of the sort. Before I realized, like, I was great.
那是夸张了，但差不多是那种感觉。在那之前，我以为我很棒。
And what about after?
那之后呢？
Um, nobody can save me. It's me, myself, and I, and whatever problem surrounds me. These are the only people, the only things, that are around me, and there's nothing that can help me but me. And that's a scary thought for, like, a seven-year-old.
嗯，没人能救我。只能靠我自己，以及周围的任何问题。这些就是我周围仅有的人和事，除了我自己，没什么能帮我。这对一个七岁的孩子来说是个可怕的想法。
For anybody.
对任何人来说都是。
For anyone, but especially a seven-year-old.
对谁都是，但对七岁的孩子尤其如此。
Yeah.
是的。
That's a pretty enormous leap, right, from "my dad takes a minute to wake up" to "I'm totally alone in the universe." But I think this is what can happen when you're faced with the fallibility of adults in front of you. One tiny moment, and your mind takes you to all sorts of huge conclusions.
这跨度相当巨大，对吧？从“我爸爸叫醒要花点时间”到“我在宇宙中完全孤独”。但我认为当你面对眼前成年人的不可靠时，就会发生这种事。一个小小的瞬间，你的大脑就会让你得出各种巨大的结论。
You enter this kind of freefall, and it doesn't just happen with parents. It doesn't just happen when you're young either. You can keep having these moments with all sorts of grown people-- adults you'd previously assumed were all-knowing, maybe omniscient, but instead are fallible, ignorant, or just tired.
你会进入一种失重状态，这不仅发生在父母身上，而且不仅仅发生在你年轻的时候。你会不断地与各种成年人产生这种瞬间——那些你之前认为无所不知、甚至全知，但实际上却会犯错、无知或仅仅是疲惫不堪的成年人。
Today's show-- what happens in that freefall, and what happens after. We have people who are entering the post-fallibility world. The scales are just falling from their eyes. And we see how they react, how they come out of it, and what happens next. Stay with us.
今天的节目——关于那种失重状态中发生了什么，以及之后发生了什么。我们有一些正进入“后不可靠时代”的人。眼前的面纱正在落下。我们来看看他们的反应，他们是如何走出来的，以及接下来发生了什么。请继续收听。
Act One, See Something, Slay Something. Our first story is about a kid who really doesn't want to question the adults in her life. She's in middle school in Texas-- great student, likes her teachers. And she wants to trust the authority of adults, wants to believe they know what's best for her, even when the most powerful people in her school begin to make that very difficult.
第一幕，看到什么，解决什么。我们的第一个故事是关于一个并不想质疑她生活中成年人的女孩。她在德克萨斯州上初中——是个好学生，喜欢她的老师。她想信任成年人的权威，想相信他们知道什么对自己最好，即使在她学校里最有权势的人开始让这一切变得非常困难时。
Talia Richman covers education for the Dallas Morning News. She tells us what happened.
Talia Richman是《达拉斯晨报》的教育记者。她告诉我们发生了什么。
When the story begins, Madison was 13, starting eighth grade. And she'd finally cracked the middle school code. She had a good group of friends-- people from her cheer team and some kids in the theater program. She messaged them all the time in group chats, said they were like a lunch table she could carry around in her pocket. And she was speaking up more in class, like in math, her favorite subject.
故事开始时，Madison 13岁，刚上八年级。她终于破解了初中生存法则。她有一群好朋友——啦啦队队员和戏剧社的一些孩子。她们经常在群聊里发消息，她说那就像她随身携带的午餐桌。而且她在课堂上发言更积极了，比如数学，她最喜欢的科目。
It's not like reading and writing, where there could be an infinite amount of answers to what does this poem mean. But in math, there's always a singular answer to a question.
这不像阅读和写作，对同一首诗的含义可能有一万种解读。但在数学里，一个问题永远只有一个答案。
I wish I felt that way about math.
真希望我也能对数学有这种感觉。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
But when you can never get to the singular answer, it's not so fun.
但当你永远得不出那个唯一答案时，那就不那么好玩了。
Yeah.
是啊。
Madison hoped to get into this prestigious high school program, the same one her older brother and sister had gone to. She seemed totally on track to do that-- until this one morning, her second semester, January 26. Madison was in second-period PE, sitting in her assigned spot toward the bleachers. And she noticed the new kid in class in front of her. He was talking to another boy, and she heard the new kid say something.
Madison希望能进入那个久负盛名的项目，她哥哥姐姐也都进过的那种。她看起来完全走在正轨上——直到那个早晨，第二学期，1月26日。Madison在上第二节体育课，坐在靠近看台的指定位置。她注意到前面有个新来的男同学。他在和另一个男孩说话，她听到那个新来的说了些什么。
So I heard this kid was telling his friend don't come to school tomorrow. And the other kid asked, why. And the kid was like, don't worry about it. I don't think my mind first went to a gun threat, because I subconsciously didn't think that kid was a danger. I mean, he was a new kid. And it was like, well, it could have just been a joke.
我听到那个孩子告诉他的朋友明天别来学校。另一个孩子问，为什么。那个孩子就说，别担心。我的大脑起初并没有联想到枪击威胁，因为我潜意识里没觉得那个孩子有危险。我的意思是，他是个新来的。而且就像是，好吧，可能只是个玩笑。
The bell rings. Madison leaves the gym, goes through the rest of her school day. Then, in the last class of the day, she starts thinking about what she heard-- "Don't come to school tomorrow."
下课铃响了。Madison离开体育馆，继续她剩下的课程。然后，在当天的最后一节课上，她开始琢磨听到的那句话——“明天别来学校”。
Then I was like, well, I can't just not take that seriously. And I really started getting stressed out over it. And I think the only thing that was going through my head is, I can't keep this to myself. And I wasn't going to be able to do anything alone with that information. Like, I had to tell someone.
然后我心想，好吧，我不能就这么不当回事。我真的开始为此感到压力巨大。我想我脑子里唯一想的就是，我不能把这事藏在心里。而且仅凭这些信息，我自己什么也做不了。就像，我必须告诉某人。
Madison was a toddler when Sandy Hook happened. As far back as she remembers, her schools had done lockdown drills every year. In her middle school, there are posters telling kids, "See something, say something." When school lets out, she decides to text one of her closest friends.
桑迪胡克小学枪击案发生时，Madison还是个蹒跚学步的孩子。从她记事起，她的学校每年都进行封锁演习。在她的初中，到处贴着标语告诉孩子，“看到什么，就要说出来。”放学后，她决定给最好的朋友发短信。
I wanted validation that my suspicions may be correct.
我想确认一下我的怀疑是否正确。
She explains what she heard the new boy in PE say. And she texts, "I can't remember if he was smiling or not, but I don't think he was." The more Madison tells her friend, the more worried the friend gets. "WTF," she writes in all caps. "That's crazy."
她解释了在体育课上听到那个新来的男生说的话。她发短信说：“我不记得他当时是不是在笑，但我觉得他没有。”Madison告诉朋友的越多，朋友就越担心。“WTF，”她用全大写字母写道。“太疯狂了。”
Madison and her friend agree to message a handful of their best friends across two group chats, to tell them what she overheard and to warn them. Then Madison tells her friends she's going to talk with her mom.
Madison和她的朋友们商定在两个群聊里通知一小群好朋友，告诉她们听到的话并提醒她们。然后Madison告诉朋友她要跟妈妈说。
I said, whoa, hold on.
我说，等等，等一下。
This is her mom, Lisa.
这是她妈妈，Lisa。
It was, like, 4:45, 4:50. And so I was like, OK, everyone's gone. Give Mom a second. I started pacing the floor, because I was like, who can I reach out to so that we can escalate this concern.
当时大概是4:45、4:50。所以我就想，好吧，大家都走了。给妈妈一分钟。我开始在房间里踱步，因为我在想，我能联系谁来处理这个担忧。
Lisa regularly uses phrases like, "escalate this concern." She's an operations director, manages more than 100 employees. She's good at putting out fires. Her kids sometimes say that Mom is in her Olivia Pope mode.
Lisa经常使用“处理这个担忧”之类的短语。她是运营总监，管理着100多名员工。她很擅长灭火。她的孩子们有时说，妈妈正处于“奥利维亚·波普”模式（编者注：美剧《丑闻》中擅长公关危机处理的角色）。
And so what Mom needs you to do now is to cease and desist on any further conversation and let some adults look into it. And about that time, my phone rang, and it was Ms. Samples.
所以妈妈现在需要你做的是，停止一切进一步的谈话，让一些成年人去调查。就在那时，电话响了，是Samples女士。
Ms. Sharla Samples is the assistant principal at Madison's school. She was calling because the school had actually gotten wind of the situation already, because of Madison's text to her friends. Word travels fast in a middle school.
Sharla Samples女士是Madison学校的助理校长。她打电话是因为学校已经察觉到了情况，因为Madison给朋友发了短信。在初中，消息传得很快。
And so I said, you know, thank you for calling. Madison just alerted me to a concern, and I was just trying to figure out how to contact you.
所以我说，你知道，谢谢你打来电话。Madison刚刚提醒我一个担忧，我正想办法联系你们。
Ms. Samples wanted to know more details from Lisa and Madison. Madison cried as she told her everything over speakerphone. Ms. Samples was reassuring.
Samples女士想从Lisa和Madison那里了解更多细节。Madison在免提通话中哭着说了一切。Samples女士表现得很让人安心。
And she told me at the end of the phone call that she was going to take care of it and that school was going to be safe.
她在电话最后告诉我，她会处理这件事的，学校会很安全的。
Later that evening, school police went to the boy's house. They found no weapons and no intent to carry out violence of any kind. It was a false alarm. Everything was OK. Everyone was safe.
那天晚些时候，学校警察去了那个男孩家。他们没发现任何武器，也没发现有实施任何形式暴力行为的意图。这只是个假警报。一切都好。每个人都很安全。
So the school shooting scare was just that-- a scare. In my experience as an education reporter, that sort of thing happens all the time. What I'd never seen is what happened to Madison the next day at school.
所以那场校园枪击恐慌就仅仅是一场虚惊。作为一名教育记者，这种事经常发生。但我从未见过像Madison第二天在学校经历的那样。
During first period, Madison gets called to Ms. Samples' office. That's the assistant principal who called Lisa and Madison the night before. Madison had actually never been to the principal's office before. She thinks maybe they have an update about yesterday.
第一节课期间，Madison被叫到了Samples女士的办公室。就是前一天晚上给Lisa和Madison打电话的那位助理校长。Madison以前从来没进过校长办公室。她以为可能是有关于昨天的更新。
So I go to Ms. Samples' office, and she tells me, you can take a seat.
所以我去了Samples女士的办公室，她告诉我，你可以坐下。
Ms. Samples, in her assistant-principal kind of way, asked Madison some questions about the day before, asked to see the texts Madison sent her friends. Madison shows her the texts, tries to answer all of her questions. Ms. Samples looks over everything, and then she turns to Madison.
Samples女士以助理校长的方式问了Madison一些前一天的问题，要求看Madison发给朋友的短信。Madison展示了短信，并试图回答她所有的问题。Samples女士看了看一切，然后转向Madison。
And she says, so I was looking through the evidence that I gathered. And I've decided that this was a false accusation.
她说，我查看了收集到的证据。我决定这是一项虚假指控。
Ms. Samples had determined that, by texting her friends first before telling an adult, she had essentially spread a rumor that there'd be a school shooting. And page 11 of the student code of conduct said students cannot, quote, "make false accusations or perpetrate hoaxes regarding school safety."
Samples女士认定，由于Madison在告诉成年人之前先给朋友发了短信，她实际上散布了会有校园枪击的谣言。而学生行为准则第11页规定，学生不得，引述，“就学校安全问题进行虚假指控或制造恶作剧”。
At first, I was like, wait, I'm in trouble? Like, I could barely comprehend what she was saying. I was very confused, because they told us, "see something, say something." And I did do that.
起初，我想，等等，我有麻烦了？就像，我几乎无法理解她在说什么。我非常困惑，因为他们告诉我们，“看到什么，就要说出来。”我确实照做了。
And she told me that we all have to face the consequences of our actions. And she said, unfortunately, the punishment is DAEP placement.
她告诉我说，我们都必须面对自己行为的后果。她说，不幸的是，处罚是进入DAEP（纪律替代教育项目）。
DAEP stands for Disciplinary Alternative Education Program. It's Texas's version of school for kids with serious discipline problems-- a place where kids get sent for fighting or selling drugs. Madison didn't know much about DAEP, except that it was a bad thing. And this wouldn't be some quick stint at DAEP. She'd be going there for the next 73 school days-- the rest of eighth grade.
DAEP代表纪律替代教育项目。这是德克萨斯州为有严重纪律问题的孩子设立的学校——因为打架或贩毒被送去的地方。Madison对DAEP了解不多，只知道那不是什么好地方。而且这还不是DAEP的短期学习。她要在那里度过接下来的73个上课日——八年级剩下的时间。
And I remember, like, my jaw physically dropped. And it took me a minute to process what she said. Because before this, I felt like I was doing the right thing and that I was helping.
我记得，我的下巴惊得掉了下来。我花了一分钟才消化她所说的话。因为在此之前，我觉得我做的是对的事，而且我在帮忙。
So she gave me some tissues, because I started crying. And I sat there, like, sobbing, thinking, what am I going to do. What am I going to tell my mom?
所以她给了我一些纸巾，因为我开始哭。我坐在那里，呜咽着，心想，我该怎么办。我要怎么告诉妈妈？
When Lisa got the call from Ms. Samples, the call where Lisa would learn her daughter was being sent to DAEP for the rest of eighth grade, she was at her sister's place.
当Lisa接到Samples女士的电话，那个她得知女儿要在DAEP度过八年级剩下的时间的电话时，她正在她姐姐家。
It almost felt like I was having an out-of-body experience. It felt like she had the wrong kid. I mean, my kid's a good kid. She's never been in trouble. She doesn't talk back to teachers. They love her. They have great things to say about her.
那感觉就像灵魂出窍。感觉就像她找错了孩子。我的意思是，我的孩子是个好孩子。她从来没惹过麻烦。她从不顶撞老师。他们喜欢她。他们对她评价很高。
I was so out of my mind that I thought, I'm not going to remember anything this woman is saying. And so I told my sister, put your phone on record, because I'm going to need to replay this so that I can remember what she's saying.
我当时大脑一片空白，我想，我肯定记不住这个女人说的任何话。所以我告诉姐姐，把手机录音打开，因为我需要回放，这样我才能记住她在说什么。
--disruption in the school.
……学校里的干扰。
And so can I-- can I ask a question? So-- so I think that there's a lot of angles to perceive this by. I think that Maddie owes the young man an apology if she misinterpreted him. But I-- I implore you, can we talk about this some more. If there's anything--
我可以问个问题吗？我觉得这件事有很多角度可以理解。我认为如果Maddie误解了那个男孩，她欠他一个道歉。但我恳求你，我们能再谈谈这个吗？如果有什么……
We can talk about it some more.
我们可以再谈谈。
OK, if there's anything within your ability to make a different decision, then I'm pleading with you to try to look at this through a different lens.
好吧，如果你的能力范围内能做出不同的决定，那么我恳求你试着换个角度来看待这件事。
On the call, Lisa tries to get Ms. Samples to explain the school's reasoning. How did they consider this a false accusation?
通话中，Lisa试图让Samples女士解释学校的理由。他们怎么会认为这是虚假指控？
Her claim was-- is that a kid said, don't come to school tomorrow. And the kid said, why not. And the other kid said, don't worry about it. Is the false claim that that conversation never existed-- that those words were not said?
她的说法是——是一个孩子说，明天别来学校。另一个孩子问，为什么不来。那个孩子说，别担心。虚假的陈述是指那段对话从未发生过——那些话没说过吗？
It is not that the words were not said. It is that she took those words and she put her own inference on them, and then she went and told her friends that there was going to be a school shooting.
不是说那些话没说过。而是她断章取义，加上了自己的推断，然后去告诉朋友会有校园枪击案。
Ms. Samples said that students are supposed to immediately tell an adult or call an anonymous tipline after they hear something suspicious. Hearing her answer filled in part of the story for me. Because the school district, Lewisville ISD, never made Ms. Samples or any other administrators available for me to interview.
Samples女士说，学生在听到可疑的事情后应该立即告诉成年人或拨打匿名举报电话。听到她的回答，我了解了部分情况。因为刘易斯维尔独立学区从未让我采访Samples女士或任何其他行政人员。
And I think one of the biggest things that is bothersome is that she held on to the information for so long, and then she chose to spread it on. Like, she took this-- the safety of what she felt at the time, whatever she interpreted it as, and then she didn't tell the right authorities. And she spread it, and she caused a panic.
我觉得最令人困扰的一点是，她把信息扣留了这么久，然后选择了传播开来。就像，她拿走了那种她当时感受到的安全感，不管她怎么解读，她没告诉正确的当局。她传播了出去，引发了恐慌。
Right, but--
好吧，但是……
And it, essentially, is considered a false accusation in the student code of conduct.
这实质上在学生行为准则中被视为虚假指控。
And so for waiting all day, then texting her friends about 30 minutes before telling her mom, they were giving Madison 73 school days in DAEP-- kicking her out of her middle school.
所以因为等了一整天，然后在告诉她妈妈前30分钟给朋友发了短信，他们就给了Madison 73个DAEP上课日——把她赶出了初中。
When Lisa first told me about her daughter's punishment, I think I gasped a half-dozen times. I had never heard of anything like this. In another big Texas district, fighting another student could get you up to 45 days in DAEP on your third offense. Making a, quote, "terroristic threat" would get you 30 days.
当Lisa第一次告诉我她女儿的惩罚时，我想我倒吸了好几口冷气。我从未听说过这种事。在德克萨斯州另一个大地区，与同学打架在第三次违规时最高也只会让你在DAEP待45天。做出所谓的“恐怖威胁”也只会让你待30天。
I couldn't make sense of why Madison's middle school was throwing the book at her. It is true that schools across the US are dealing with a big increase in shooting threats. Some are hoaxes, but a hoax can still disrupt school. And threats that turn out to be fake-- those still scare kids and parents.
我无法理解为什么Madison的初中要对她下如此重手。全美各地的学校确实都在处理枪击威胁大幅增加的问题。有些是恶作剧，但恶作剧仍然会干扰学校。而事后证明是假的威胁——这些仍然会吓到孩子和家长。
So maybe Madison's middle school felt like they had to take a tough stance on kids who were involved in any way in a threat that doesn't materialize. But 73 days? Lisa was also racking her brain for an explanation. And she told me, at first, she didn't let herself consider that a punishment this severe had anything to do with the fact that Madison, like her, is Black.
所以也许Madison的初中觉得他们必须对任何以任何方式卷入未成真威胁的孩子采取强硬立场。但73天？Lisa也在绞尽脑汁寻找解释。她告诉我，起初，她没让自己去想这种严厉的惩罚与Madison像她一样是黑人有关。
And I really tried to keep my mind away from that. But she's 5' 6", she wears her hair natural, very big, very proud. And I just felt like maybe she wasn't being given the same lens that they would look at a fair, blue-eyed, petite girl.
我真的试着让自己的思维避开那个层面。但她身高5尺6寸，留着天然发型，非常高大，非常骄傲。我只是觉得，也许她们并没有像对待一个白皙、蓝眼睛、娇小的女孩那样去审视她。
Black students are often given a different lens when it comes to school discipline. Federal civil rights investigations have repeatedly found evidence of Black kids being punished more severely for the same things that a white kid might get away with.
黑人学生在学校纪律方面往往面临不同的审视标准。联邦民权调查一再发现黑人孩子因同样的错误而受到比白人孩子更严厉惩罚的证据。
In Madison's school district, only 12% of students are Black. But in the latest data, they made up 33% of all kids in DAEP. Lisa was hyperconscious of maintaining her cool during the phone call.
在Madison的学区，只有12%的学生是黑人。但在最新的数据中，她们占了DAEP所有孩子的33%。Lisa在通话中极度克制，保持冷静。
If I went in there being irate, I was just going to be another angry Black woman. So I kept it very even-toned, because I wanted to negotiate. I wanted you to feel comfortable enough and not have your defenses up to talk with me. Let's lay this out, and let's talk about this.
如果我愤怒地去交涉，我就会成为又一个愤怒的黑人女性。所以我保持了非常平和的语调，因为我想谈判。我希望你感到足够舒服，放下戒备与我交谈。让我们摆出事实，谈谈这个。
Sure. And so here's another question for you, is, so--
好的。那么这里还有另一个问题要问你，就是……
Ms. Samples keeps trying to explain the disruption Madison caused and how she potentially tarnished the boy's reputation at school. Sure, Lisa agrees, that is bad. But--
Samples女士一直试图解释Madison造成的干扰，以及她如何可能玷污了那个男孩在学校的名声。当然，Lisa同意，那很糟糕。但是……
We're holding her to a standard of a grownup with a mature brain. And she's a 13-year-old who made an error, but it wasn't done with malice. But this punishment feels very punitive, as though she did whatever she did with malice. And I keep using that word, "malice." She seriously thought there was a threat. So I really wish that we could talk through this some more and think of other ways to make this a learning opportunity for Madison and not turning her into a juvenile delinquent.
我们以拥有成熟大脑的成年人的标准来要求她。而她只是一个犯了错的13岁孩子，但这并非出于恶意。但这个惩罚感觉非常有惩罚性，就好像她所做的一切都是出于恶意。我一直在用“恶意”这个词。她当时确实认为存在威胁。所以我真的希望我们能再讨论一下，想想其他方法来把这变成Madison的学习机会，而不是把她变成一个少年犯。
I understand your point.
我理解你的观点。
Ms. Samples listens but stays firm. She tells Lisa, there's a formal process if you want to appeal this. But she isn't going to undo or reduce the punishment or explain its severity.
Samples女士听了，但立场坚定。她告诉Lisa，如果你想上诉，有一个正式程序。但她不会撤销或减轻处罚，也不会解释处罚的严厉性。
Lisa does decide to appeal the school's decision. The administration gives her a hearing date, and Lisa goes into Olivia Pope mode-- spends hours each day preparing a defense of her daughter. She keeps Madison at home, out of alternative school, as they wait for the appeal hearing, which leaves Madison with a lot of time to think about the punishment and what this will mean for her future plans.
Lisa确实决定对学校的决定提出上诉。行政部门给了她听证会日期，Lisa开启了“奥利维亚·波普”模式——每天花几个小时为女儿辩护。她让Madison待在家里，不去替代学校，同时等待上诉听证会。这让Madison有大量时间思考惩罚以及这对她未来的计划意味着什么。
And one thought really seeds inside her. What if Ms. Samples' punishment is really bad because what I did was really bad?
一个念头在她心中扎了根。如果Samples女士的惩罚这么重，是因为我做的真的很糟糕吗？
Like, in my eyes, I thought, like, she knows what she's doing. And she knows the correct punishments to give. And I shouldn't question it.
就像，在我眼里，我想，她知道她在做什么。她知道该给什么样正确的惩罚。我不该质疑她。
What's behind that belief? Is that how you've always felt about school principals?
那种信念背后是什么？你一直以来对学校校长都是这么看的吗？
Yeah. I thought that there were rules there for a reason, and the principals put them there because they know what they're doing. And, you know--
是啊。我以为规矩摆在那里是有原因的，校长把它们定在那里是因为他们知道自己在做什么。而且，你知道……
For a kid who's never been to the principal's office before, it's a powerful feeling, and it begins to take a toll on her. She starts eating less. Her doctor puts her on anti-anxiety medications.
对于一个从未进过校长办公室的孩子来说，这是一种强烈的心理冲击，并开始对她造成伤害。她开始吃得更少。她的医生给她开了抗焦虑药。
The appeal takes place at the middle school 12 days after Madison got in trouble. It feels like a court date. Madison, her mom, and her grandma show up with the family's new lawyer. They sit at a table, along with Ms. Samples and the head principal, Dr. Beri Deister. Both women are white.
上诉在Madison惹麻烦12天后在初中进行。感觉就像一场法庭审判。Madison、她妈妈和她祖母带着家里请的新律师出现了。她们坐在桌子旁，旁边是Samples女士和校长Beri Deister博士。两位女性都是白人。
What were you thinking about seeing Samples and Deister for the first time since this happened? Did you have an idea of how you wanted to come off to them?
你第一次见到Samples和Deister时在想什么？对于你想给她们留下什么印象，你有想法吗？
Well, at first, I just wanted to be as polite as I could. But then my grandma was like, stop smiling. [CHUCKLES]
嗯，起初，我只想表现得尽可能有礼貌。但后来我祖母说，别笑了。[轻笑]
Why do you think she said that?
你觉得她为什么这么说？
Because she said, we're not here to be friends.
因为她说，我们不是来做朋友的。
Did you agree?
你同意吗？
I don't think I, like, fully-- like, fully agreed.
我觉得我没能……完全同意。
Madison knows that the point of this appeal is to get the punishment reversed, to get her official record cleared and to get herself back into normal eighth grade. But that's not all Madison wants out of this hearing.
Madison知道这次上诉的目的是撤销惩罚，洗清正式记录，并让她回到正常的八年级生活。但Madison从听证会中想要得到的不仅仅是这些。
What were you hoping that you could get them to understand about your situation?
你希望她们能了解关于你处境的什么情况？
That I wasn't the kid that they were seeing me as. And maybe they saw me wrong. Maybe they just don't know me enough.
我不是她们眼里看到的那个孩子。也许她们看错我了。也许她们只是不够了解我。
What was the kid they were seeing you as, in your mind?
在你心里，她们眼中的你是什么样的孩子？
Not a good kid. The kind who would cause trouble and lie about stuff. I was thinking maybe if we have all these advocates for me-- my mom, my grandma, this lawyer-- that we could give the facts, rationalize, and just talk it through with them, and it would all be OK.
不是好孩子。那种会惹麻烦、撒谎的人。我心想，也许如果我们有这么多支持者——我妈妈、祖母、这位律师——我们就能提供事实，理清逻辑，好好跟她们谈谈，一切都会好起来的。
All right. Let's begin. This hearing is convened on February 8, 2023, for the purpose of an appeal of a--
好了，开始吧。本次听证会于2023年2月8日举行，目的是上诉……
Dr. Deister, the head principal, kicks things off. First, she asked Ms. Samples to review the school's official timeline of events. The tone is pretty damning toward Madison.
校长Deister博士开始了。首先，她要求Samples女士回顾学校的官方事件时间表。语气对Madison非常不利。
Madison's choice had a great impact on many different people. Several people were scared about the safety of the school because her messages started spreading. Communication had to be sent out to the whole school community, because the message started spreading--
Madison的选择对许多人产生了巨大的影响。因为她的信息开始传播，几个人担心学校的安全。必须向整个学校社区发出通知，因为消息开始传播……
My hands were shaking. I remember feeling like I was in her office again.
我的手在颤抖。我记得感觉又回到了她的办公室。
At this time, the student and/or those wishing to speak on a student's behalf are invited to do so.
此时，邀请学生和/或希望代表学生发言的人员发言。
This is Dr. Deister again.
这是Deister博士。
This is your opportunity to explain why you disagree with the investigation findings or the disciplinary decision and what outcome you are requesting.
这是你解释为什么不同意调查结果或纪律处分决定，以及你要求什么结果的机会。
I had prepared what I was going to say, because I didn't want to be emotional. And Madison-- I knew she was agitated, and she looked nervous. She looked-- she looked really nervous.
我已经准备好了要说的话，因为我不想情绪化。而Madison——我知道她很焦躁，看起来很紧张。她看起来……她看起来非常紧张。
Just, like, in her eyes?
仅仅是透过她的眼睛吗？
Yeah, I could see it in her eyes. Um-- (EMOTIONALLY) I didn't want to let her down. I did not want to let her down.
对，我能从她眼睛里看出来。嗯……（情绪激动）我不想让她失望。我不想让她失望。
Thank you for allowing me to respond to the assertions that Madison engaged in perpetrating a false hoax or disrupting school.
谢谢你们允许我回应关于Madison参与制造虚假恶作剧或扰乱学校秩序的断言。
Lisa peppers her rebuttal with references to the Texas education statutes.
Lisa在反驳中引用了德克萨斯州的教育法规。
And then, under Section 4206, it goes on to say that the student has to knowingly initiate that they are making a false claim that is baseless or false. So Madison did not violate this code.
而且，根据第4206条，文中指出学生必须是有意识地发起虚假指控，即它是毫无根据或虚假的。所以Madison并没有违反这项准则。
And then she asked them to remember that Madison's a kid, how it's a normal thing for kids to check in with their friends for advice.
然后她请她们记住Madison是个孩子，孩子向朋友寻求建议是很正常的事。
I think that the school did the right thing by jumping into action and making the assessment that this was not a threat. But if it had been something that he meant different when he said those words, we would be thanking Madison for raising the bell.
我认为学校通过采取行动并评估这不是威胁，做的是对的。但如果她说那些话时的意思不同，我们现在应该感谢Madison敲响了警钟。
Lisa concludes. Madison's grandmother speaks up for her. So does their lawyer. Then it's Madison's turn. School administrators have the right to ask Madison questions, and she's really nervous about it.
Lisa总结陈词。Madison的祖母也为她说话。律师也是。然后轮到Madison了。学校管理员有权问Madison问题，她对此非常紧张。
Um-- [CLEARS THROAT] So Madison, you and I talked a little bit. Right? Can you remind me what you said-- why you chose not to tell someone at school?
嗯……[清嗓子] 那么Madison，你和我聊过一点。对吧？你能提醒我你说了什么吗——你为什么选择不告诉学校里的人？
I believe I said it wasn't the first thing on my mind.
我想我说过，那不是我脑子里的第一选择。
OK.
好的。
I'm not sure.
我不确定。
No, OK, and I really want you to remind me. Because I know we talked about it. I just wanted to hear what you had said again. So help me understand why you put it in two different groups.
不，好的，我真的很想让你提醒我。因为我知道我们谈过。我只是想再听听你说了什么。所以帮我理解为什么你把它发给了两个不同的群体。
Um, I just wanted to make sure all of my friends knew and that they were safe.
嗯，我只是想确保我所有的朋友都知道，而且她们是安全的。
So how did it go from "don't come to school" to guns?
那么它是怎么从“明天别来学校”演变成枪支的？
Because you-- today, that's what you think of. You think there's going to be some sort of school violence at school. So--
因为你——今天，这就是你会想到的。你会觉得学校里会有某种校园暴力。所以……
But you didn't hear him say "guns," right?
但你没听到他说“枪”，对吧？
Right.
对。
It was at that moment, sitting there in her swivel chair, being interrogated by her principal, that Madison realized something.
就在那一刻，坐在转椅上，被校长审问，Madison意识到了什么。
Like, the way she asked the questions-- she wasn't trying to find out my perspective at all. And it was like a light switch being turned on. Like, oh, maybe they aren't as I see-- I saw them before. Like, they're not on my side. They were trying to form a case against me.
就像，她问问题的方式——她根本不想了解我的视角。就像开关被打开了。就像，哦，也许她们不像我之前看到的那样。她们不是站在我这边的。她们是在试图构陷我。
At the end of the hearing, Ms. Samples recommends that Madison's sentence be reduced, from 73 days in DAEP to 30 days. There is no explanation as to why. The principals were lowering Madison's punishment, but they weren't erasing it.
听证会结束时，Samples女士建议将Madison的刑期从73天DAEP缩减至30天。没有给出任何理由。校长们减轻了Madison的惩罚，但没有取消它。
Even after all of the reasoning and the logical talking we tried to do with them, they still thought that I deserved punishment. And that kind of, like, rooted the idea that, OK, they don't like me.
即使在进行了所有的推论和我们试图与她们进行的逻辑对话后，她们仍然认为我应该受到惩罚。这在某种程度上，根深蒂固了这种想法，即：好吧，她们不喜欢我。
Lisa watched her daughter from across the table. And she realized Madison was getting a lesson that Lisa had hoped she'd be able to put off for a while.
Lisa在桌子对面看着女儿。她意识到Madison正在上一节Lisa本希望推迟一段时间才上的课。
It's something she was going to learn later in life, that there were going to be cards stacked against her for being a woman, being a woman of color. There were going to be all these things that she was going to have to combat, and that I was sorry that lesson happened at 13 and not when she was older and more equipped and educated to battle it. I deal with it every day. And it-- that was sad to me.
这是她以后在生活中会学到的东西，即因为她是女性、是有色人种女性，可能会面临阻碍。会有很多事情她将不得不与之抗争，我很抱歉，这一课在13岁时就发生了，而不是在她年纪更大、更有能力和教育去战斗时。我每天都在应对这些。那让我感到悲伤。
Lisa and Madison didn't have to live with 30 days. In Madison's school district, there are three levels of appeal, and they could try it again. And this time, the judges don't work at Madison's middle school. They plead their case to a committee of three administrators from different schools in the district, not Dr. Deister. Their decision arrives by email in less than a day.
Lisa和Madison不必接受这30天。在Madison的学区，有三级上诉，她们可以再试一次。这一次，法官们不在Madison的初中工作。她们向一个由来自学区不同学校的三名行政人员组成的委员会陈述案件，而不是Deister博士。她们的决定不到一天就通过电子邮件送达。
So I was in bed. And, like, with one eye open, I saw that something came through. And so it took me a second to kind of get my vision together. But when I read it, I just ran upstairs and jumped in her bed, and I was like, we won.
当时我还在床上。眯着一只眼，我看到邮件来了。所以花了一秒钟才看清内容。但当我读到它时，我直接跑上楼跳到她床上说，我们赢了。
When educators outside the school looked at the situation, they saw Madison the way she saw herself-- as a kid who never meant to cause a disruption, a kid who maybe just needed a refresher on how to best go about reporting suspicious activity. After about three weeks of being away, Madison was cleared to go back to school.
当学校以外的教育者审视这种情况时，他们看到的Madison正是她自己眼中的那个——一个从未想过要造成干扰的孩子，一个可能只是需要复习一下如何最好地报告可疑活动的孩子。离校大约三周后，Madison被获准重返学校。
Shortly after I wrote about Madison's story for the Dallas Morning News, the district launched an investigation into the way she was punished. Dr. Deister went on administrative leave and eventually resigned. She didn't respond to request to be interviewed for this story. But in an email, she said her decision to leave was voluntary.
在我为《达拉斯晨报》写了Madison的故事后不久，学区就对她受到的惩罚方式展开了调查。Deister博士开始了行政休假，并最终辞职。她没有回应接受采访的请求。但在电子邮件中，她说她离职的决定是自愿的。
She also wrote, quote, "All I can say is that every day administrators are faced with making harder and harder decisions. And in those decision-making efforts, I have always done my best to treat others with kindness, with dignity, and to follow the district guidelines."
她还写道，引述，“我只能说，行政人员每天都在面对越来越难做的决定。在这些决策过程中，我一直尽我所能以善意、尊严对待他人，并遵循学区准则。”
This whole mess didn't derail Madison the way she feared. She's in ninth grade now. She got into that special high school program.
这一切混乱并没有像她担心的那样使Madison脱轨。她现在上九年级了。她进入了那个特别的高中项目。
I learned this word in class the other day. It's "open-minded skepticism," where you view things from both a perspective of interest, and you can also be cautious about things and be skeptical.
我前几天在课上学了这个词。“开明的怀疑主义”，即你以兴趣的视角看待事物，同时也能对事物保持谨慎和怀疑。
And that was your new worldview?
这就是你的新世界观？
Yeah.
是啊。
And it felt different from before, in that it was all open-minded, none of the skepticism?
这和以前感觉不同，以前是完全开明，一点怀疑都没有？
Right.
没错。
Madison says it was so much easier back when she just believed she could trust every adult. This new way of dealing with the world, where she has to figure out which adult she can trust and which ones deserve her skepticism-- it just takes a lot more brainpower.
Madison说，以前只要相信自己能信任每个成年人时，生活要容易得多。这种处理世界的新方式，让她必须弄清楚该信任哪个成年人，而哪些成年人值得她的怀疑——这需要耗费更多的脑力。
Talia Richmond is a reporter with the Dallas Morning News. This story was produced by Chris Benderev.
Talia Richmond是《达拉斯晨报》的记者。这个故事由Chris Benderev制作。
In preparing today's episode, we asked a bunch of people when they had this kind of realization that adults are flawed. People talked about moments when they saw adults lie, make mistakes, be reckless, cry in front of them.
在准备今天这一期节目时，我们问了一堆人，他们什么时候意识到成年人是有缺陷的。人们谈到了他们看到成年人撒谎、犯错、鲁莽、在他们面前哭泣的时刻。
A woman who brought her friends from college back to the farm where she grew up to meet her parents and her dad started acting really distant. And she realized, oh, my god. He's intimidated. But the kind of experience we heard the most was like Madison had-- the realization that adults might not be looking out for you, might not protect you.
一位带大学朋友回农场看望父母的女性，她爸爸开始表现得很冷漠。她意识到，天哪。他在感到卑怯。但我们听到的最多的那种经历就像Madison的那样——意识到成年人可能不会照顾你，可能不会保护你。
We heard several stories about experiencing real school shootings and lockdowns. And in those stories, what stood out to people was the way adults fumbled. A 20-year-old college student named Adele Morris told us that two weeks after a gunman shot and killed a teacher at her school, the University of North Carolina, they had another lockdown-- someone armed on campus. And Adele watched her professor, someone who probably didn't grow up having lockdown drills like she had.
我们听到了几个经历过真正的校园枪击和封锁的故事。而在那些故事中，让人们记忆深刻的是成年人那种笨拙的方式。一位名叫Adele Morris的20岁大学生告诉我们，在她所在的北卡罗来纳大学一名枪手枪杀了一名老师两周后，他们又遭遇了一次封锁——校园里有人持械。Adele看着她的教授，一个可能不像她那样从小经历封锁演习的人。
He didn't turn off the lights. I don't remember if-- he didn't lock the door very quickly. He actually started playing skits-- and it was my Portuguese class-- Portuguese skits on the smartboard, like, really loudly. And I just didn't know what was going on.
他没关灯。我不记得了……他没有很快锁上门。他实际上开始播放小品——那是我的葡萄牙语课——葡萄牙语小品在智能黑板上，声音很大。我根本不知道发生了什么。
You don't know where the gunman is. And at a really loud volume, it was kind of unsettling to me. I mean, some of the professors led a-- one of my friends' professors led a round of applause for the maintenance men who had come and locked the door, even though there was a gunman on campus and you're not supposed to make noise.
你不知道枪手在哪里。而且声音那么大，让我感到非常不安。我的意思是，有些教授带领——我朋友的一位教授为进来锁门的维修工领头鼓掌，尽管校园里有枪手，按规定不该制造噪音。
Adults who fail to protect children-- there's the abstract fear that adults can't protect you, and there's watching it happen right in front of you. I've been thinking, watching the news from Gaza and Israel this week, and the week before that, and the weeks before those, about how many children are experiencing the most terrifying version of this-- the most brutal version of adults not having a handle on things.
未能保护孩子的成年人——有一种成年人无法保护你的抽象恐惧，也有亲眼目睹它发生的现实。我一直在想，看着本周以及前几周有关加沙和以色列的新闻，想到有多少孩子正在经历这件事最可怕的版本——最残酷的成年人无法掌控局面的版本。
We are all witnessing children who are directly facing the fact that the adults around them cannot protect them. Children facing that fact, not as part of a slow understanding of adult fallibility as they age and develop, but as a sudden reckoning-- a 3-and-1/2-year-old in Israel whose parents rushed her into a safe room and kept telling her to stay quiet, because Hamas was shooting right outside. Her dad told her and her sister, stay silent.
我们都在目睹孩子们直接面对着周围的成年人无法保护他们的事实。孩子们面对这个事实，不是作为他们成长过程中对成年人不可靠性缓慢理解的一部分，而是一次突然的清算——以色列一个3岁半的孩子，她的父母把她冲进安全屋，一直告诉她保持安静，因为哈马斯就在外面开枪。她爸爸告诉她和她姐姐，保持安静。
And he kept telling her that for 10 hours. He could not stop what was happening. He could just tell her to keep quiet. That's all he could do for her.
而且他连续10个小时一直告诉她保持安静。他无法阻止正在发生的一切。他只能告诉她保持安静。这就是他能为她做的全部。
A video from Gaza shows two kids, siblings, holding hands in the street right after an Israeli airstrike. They've just come out from under the rubble, and they're covered in dust and blood. They're looking around for their mom and their brother. Around them, the street is chaotic. People are moving in every direction.
一段来自加沙的视频显示，在一次以色列空袭后，两个孩子，兄妹，在街上手拉手。他们刚从瓦砾下出来，浑身是灰尘和血迹。他们在四处寻找妈妈和兄弟。周围街道乱作一团。人们朝四面八方奔走。
The older kid spots his brother on the other side of the street and yells, that's my brother! Here's my brother, the one in blue! That's my brother! He can't get to him. He needs the help of an adult. Please, I'm begging you, he says. That's my brother.
较大的孩子在街对面看到了他的弟弟，大喊，那是我弟弟！那是我弟弟，穿蓝色衣服的那个！那是我弟弟！他够不到他。他需要成年人的帮助。求求你们，我求求你们，他说。那是我弟弟。
A few adults do help. They rush over to the brother. He's tiny, crying, with a bloody nose. Come here, they say. They guide him to his siblings, take their hands, and join them. Now, the three kids are hand in hand, looking up at the adults.
几个成年人确实帮忙了。他们冲向那个弟弟。他很小，正在哭，鼻子流血。过来，他们说。他们引导他去他的兄妹那里，拉住他们的手，加入他们。现在，三个孩子手拉手，抬头看着成年人。
The tiny kid says, I need my mom. But nobody produces the mom. When the video ends, the adults look like they're about to continue on and rejoin the chaos around them. The three kids are left there, holding hands.
最小的孩子说，我需要妈妈。但没人找来妈妈。当视频结束时，成年人看起来正准备继续走开，重新融入周围的混乱中。这三个孩子被留在那儿，手拉着手。
Coming up-- a man-sized first-grader. That's in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来——一个成人身材的一年级学生。一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, we're talking about those experiences where you discover the grownups around you can and will fail you-- a revelation that can take a long time to sink in, as it does in our next story from comedian Gary Gulman. That's Act Two, Dad's Big Idea.
这是《美国生活》。我是Chana Joffe-Walt，代替Ira Glass主持。今天的节目，我们讨论那些你发现周围成年人能够且将会让你失望的经历——这种领悟可能需要很长时间才能沉淀下来，正如我们在下一位喜剧演员Gary Gulman的故事中看到的那样。这是第二幕，爸爸的大主意。
Gary Gulman tells a story on stage about something that happened when he was seven years old. He was about to go into second grade. And right before the school year started that September, his mom had some friends over one night.
Gary Gulman在舞台上讲了一个发生在他七岁时的故事。他那时准备上二年级。就在那年9月学年开始之前，他妈妈一天晚上请了一些朋友过来。
So on that night in my house, there had to be 24 or 25 moms. And in the 1970s, that meant there were probably four Carols. There were six Phyllises or Phylli.
那天晚上在我家，大概有24或25个妈妈。在20世纪70年代，那意味着可能有四个Carol。有六个Phyllis或Phylli。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
There were two Auntie Judys, and there was one Just Judy. And Just Judy was Judy Burns, who was royalty in our neighborhood, because she was the first-grade teacher, and she was also my next-door neighbor. And she was sitting in my kitchen.
有两个Judy阿姨，还有一个Just Judy。Just Judy就是Judy Burns，她在我们社区地位很高，因为她是小学一年级老师，也是我的邻居。她当时正坐在我的厨房里。
It was like having a celebrity there, and-- and she was so down-to-earth. She was able to maintain that idea that Kipling so beautifully espoused in the poem, "If--," where she was able to walk with kings, yet keep the common touch. She just sat like she was just one of us.
这就像有个名人坐在那儿，而且……她那么平易近人。她能够保持基普林在诗歌《如果》中优美表达的那种想法，即能够与国王同行，却保持平民本色。她坐着就好像是我们的一员。
And so I was so excited to see her, and I tried to maintain my composure. But not only was she my favorite teacher, she was also the mother of my favorite person in the world-- Jonathan Burns. Jonathan Burns was in fourth grade. But in the 1970s, a fourth-grader was lawfully permitted to be your legal guardian.
所以我非常兴奋见到她，我努力保持镇定。但她不仅是我最喜欢的老师，还是我世界上最喜欢的人——Jonathan Burns的母亲。Jonathan Burns读四年级。但在70年代，四年级学生在法律上被允许成为你的法定监护人。
They permitted him to take me anywhere. Two summers before, he had taken me to see Jaws-- when I was five. And I just loved Jonathan Burns, and his mom was in my kitchen. And I tried to play it cool and just-- I said, hey, Mrs. Burns, how was your summer?
他们允许他带我去任何地方。两年前的夏天，他带我去看了《大白鲨》——当时我才五岁。我真的很喜欢Jonathan Burns，而他妈妈正在我的厨房里。我努力保持冷静，只是……我说，嘿，Burns太太，你的暑假过得怎么样？
And she said-- and she said, oh, it was excellent, Gary. How was your summer? And I said, it was good. It was good. And then, I couldn't suppress my enthusiasm, and I just-- I cut right to the chase. I said, you talk to Jonathan?
她说——她说，哦，过得很好，Gary。你的暑假过得怎么样？我说，很好。很好。然后，我无法抑制我的热情，我直接切入正题。我说，你跟Jonathan说话吗？
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And she laughed. She said, yes, Gary, I talk to my son nearly every day. And then, I ran out of small talk, and I thought I'd get in a little bit of business. I wanted to get down to the nitty grit.
她笑了。她说，是的，Gary，我几乎每天都和我的儿子说话。然后，我没话找话，我想深入了解一下具体情况。
And I said, Mrs. Burns, um, I know this might be out of order and everything, but can you tell me who I'm going to have for second grade? Am I going to have Morrison or Mrs. Turner? And she looked at me in a way I felt there was something off.
我说，Burns太太，嗯，我知道这可能有点不合规矩，但你能告诉我我二年级会被分到谁的班吗？我是会被分到Morrison还是Turner太太的班？她看着我的方式让我觉得有些不对劲。
And she said, Gary, your father hasn't told you? And I said, no, I see him from noon to 7:00 on Sundays, according to the divorce decree.
她说，Gary，你爸爸没告诉你吗？我说，没有，根据离婚协议，我每周日中午到七点才见他。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And she said, well, Gary, your father went to the principal, and then the superintendent of schools, insisting that you repeat the first grade. And at that moment, I invented a phrase that is quite commonplace now but had never been uttered in September of 1977. I said, "wait, what?"
她说，嗯，Gary，你爸爸去了校长办公室，然后是学校督学，坚持要你重读一年级。就在那一刻，我发明了一个现在很常见但在此前1977年9月从未说过的短语。我说，“等一下，什么？”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I remember I said, but Mrs. Burns, I was in the top reading group, Sun Up. Sun Up was the top reading group. We read beautifully, never had to put our finger under it, never had to sound anything out. The other groups-- ugh, it was like a sideshow.
我记得我说，但是Burns太太，我是在最高阅读小组Sun Up里的。Sun Up是最高阅读小组。我们读得很漂亮，从来不需要把手指放在下面，从来不需要拼读任何东西。其他小组……呃，那简直像个滑稽表演。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Isn't that how you determine whether somebody should go to second grade-- whether they can read? I said, what reason did he give? And she said, he didn't feel you were mature enough. And we showed him charts and studies showing what damage and impact this will have on a kid.
难道这不是判断一个人是否该升二年级的标准吗——他会不会阅读？我说，他给了什么理由？她说，他觉得你不够成熟。而且我们向他展示了图表和研究，证明这对孩子会有什么伤害和影响。
And yet, he said you weren't mature enough. He said, I know my son. And I said, he does? You're with me six hours a day, five days a week. I said, Mrs. Burns, I'm darn near precocious.
然而，他还是说你不够成熟。他说，我了解我儿子。我说，他了解吗？你每天跟我在一起六个小时，一周五天。我说，Burns太太，我简直快要“早熟”了。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
You know how a six-year-old boy knows he's precocious and how you can tell a six-year-old is precocious? He uses the word, "precocious." Because I'd been called it so frequently by so many teachers and parents in the neighborhood, and kids would tell me if my father says, you're precocious.
你知道六岁的男孩怎么知道自己早熟以及怎么看出六岁孩子早熟吗？他会用“早熟”这个词。因为我经常被社区里的许多老师和家长称为这个，孩子们会告诉我如果我爸爸说，你早熟。
I read-- my brothers-- my oldest brother was a senior accounting major, and he would open up his accounting textbook, point to a word-- it was his little parlor trick. But we would do it in the living room. Because we were not in a Tennessee Williams play.
我读书——我的哥哥们——我最大的哥哥是高级会计专业的学生，他会打开他的会计课本，指着一个词——这是他的小技巧。但我们会在客厅里这样做。因为我们不是在田纳西·威廉斯的戏里。
He would point to a word, and I would say it. And he would always pick something that was obscure. I remember one of the words he pointed to, and I said, oh, "fiduciary"? I was reading at a 16th-grade level. And also mature, because you'll notice I didn't giggle at the "douche" in "fiduciary," which you aren't even able to claim.
他会指着一个词，我会读出来。他总是挑一些生僻的词。我记得他指着其中一个词，我说，哦，“信托”？我在读16年级的水平。而且成熟，因为你会注意到我没有因为“信托”里的发音傻笑，你甚至都不能声称这一点。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
When my father came that Sunday, I said, Dad, why am I-- why am I repeating the first grade? What about when the kids tease me? And he said, you tell them your father didn't feel you were mature enough to go to second grade. And I thought, oh, yeah, that'll mollify 'em.
当我爸爸那个周日过来时，我说，爸爸，为什么我要……为什么我要重读一年级？如果孩子们嘲笑我怎么办？他说，你告诉他们你爸爸觉得你不够成熟，不能升二年级。我想，哦，是啊，那肯定能安抚他们。
And I remember, I asked my mom years later. I said, why did he hold me back, and why didn't you get in the way? And she said, well, you know Daddy. And I said, yes. And she just was afraid to argue with him. He could make her cry by getting very angry.
我记得，多年后我问我妈。我说，他为什么要留级我，而且你为什么不阻止他？她说，嗯，你知道爸爸。我说，是的。她只是不敢跟他争论。他能通过非常生气把她弄哭。
And the effect was almost immediate. When I started my second run through first grade, it was just a new me. And it started this, just-- I zealously hated school. I started faking sick. And then, I would start to get an anxious stomach every morning and just dread.
效果几乎是立竿见影的。当我第二次读一年级时，我变成了一个新我。这开启了……我极其讨厌学校。我开始装病。然后，我每天早上开始胃痛，感到焦虑和畏惧。
And it just-- it was also very difficult to make friends, because I was not only emotionally and socially more mature than these kids, I was also physically much larger than-- I was the biggest kid in the grade the first time through first grade. OK? Second time, I looked like a teacher's aide.
而且……交朋友也很困难，因为我不仅在情感和社交上比这些孩子更成熟，我在体格上也比……我第一次读一年级时就是班上最大的孩子。好吧？第二次，我看起来像个助教。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And the effect that had on me-- and it was-- I wasn't aware of it, but I realize, looking back now, that since then, I've always been trying to prove to everyone that I'm "smaht." And you can see that just by the way I talk in my act for the past 30 years. My act is bombastic, I would say, even grandiloquent.
这对我的影响——我当时没意识到，但我现在回头看才意识到，从那时起，我就一直试图向所有人证明我很“聪明”。在过去30年的表演中，你可以从我说话的方式中看出来。我的表演是夸张的，我想说，甚至是华丽的。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
I love letting my wife or anyone know that I know. We'll be listening to the radio, and she'll say, who sings this? But I hear that as, hey, could you give me a two-hour lecture on the grunge era? Also, could you assign me some reading? I didn't bring it up for a long time with anybody. I was ashamed about it. I would keep it to myself. And the interesting thing about my dad is that-- I mean, was he a bad parent? Certainly.
我喜欢让我的妻子或任何人知道我知道。我们会听收音机，她会说，这是谁唱的？但我听起来像是，嘿，你能给我讲两个小时的垃圾摇滚时代讲座吗？还有，你能给我布置点阅读作业吗？很长一段时间里我没跟任何人提过。我对此感到羞耻。我会把它藏在心里。关于我爸爸有趣的一点是——我的意思是，他是个坏父亲吗？当然。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
But he was a good person. And the mystery, which I've thought of over the years, like why he would have done this-- maybe he wanted to-- because he only saw me once a week, he wanted to have some impact on me, perhaps. And then, I had this theory after hearing the Johnny Cash version of "A Boy Named Sue."
但他是个好人。多年来我一直在思考的谜团，比如他为什么要这么做——也许他想……因为他一周只看我一次，他想对我产生一些影响，也许。然后，在听了Johnny Cash版的《一个叫Sue的男孩》之后，我有了这个理论。
And "A Boy Named Sue" is this wonderful song that was actually written by Shel Silverstein, which feels really good to tell a room full of people that might not have known that it was written by Shel Silverstein. So I'm awash in dopamine and serotonin right now, as-- I've got the chills, as I tell you that Shel Silverstein wrote "A Boy Named Sue."
《一个叫Sue的男孩》是一首美妙的歌，实际上是由Shel Silverstein写的，告诉一屋子可能不知道是Shel Silverstein写的人这首歌，感觉真好。所以此时此刻我沉浸在多巴胺和血清素中，当我告诉你Shel Silverstein写了《一个叫Sue的男孩》时，我起鸡皮疙瘩了。
But "A Boy Named Sue" is basically about this boy named Sue. And his father left him at an early age. And he said he named him Sue, so that he would have to get in a lot of fights, and it would toughen him up, and he would be strong enough to survive in a world without a father.
但《一个叫Sue的男孩》基本上是关于这个叫Sue的男孩。他父亲在他很小的时候就离开了他。他说他给他起名Sue，是为了让他不得不去打很多架，这会磨练他，让他变得足够坚强，能够在没有父亲的世界里生存。
And sometimes I think maybe that was my dad's approach-- was that he knew he wasn't going to be around that much for me, and so he wanted to make sure that when he was around, he would make such foolish decisions, that I would actually be glad he wasn't around more. All right. Thank you very much, everybody. Good night. Thank you.
有时我觉得也许那是我爸爸的方式——他知道他不会花太多时间陪我，所以他想确保当他在身边时，他会做出如此愚蠢的决定，以至于我其实很高兴他没更多地出现在我身边。好了。非常感谢大家。晚安。谢谢。
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
Gary Gulman recorded in Florida. He's on a tour, where he's doing standup based on stories in his new book. It's a memoir of his childhood, called Misfit.
Gary Gulman在佛罗里达录制的。他正在巡演，表演基于他新书中故事的单口喜剧。那是他童年的回忆录，叫《怪胎》。
Act Three, Ride or Die. The idea that grownups don't have a handle on things-- there are kids for whom this is not a new realization-- kids who are more adult than the adults in their house. These kids look at the conditions around them and understand that they are going to need to handle things.
第三幕，生死之交。成年人无法掌控局面的想法——有些孩子并不是第一次意识到这一点——有些孩子比他们家里的成年人更成熟。这些孩子看着周围的情况，明白他们将需要处理这些事情。
I keep thinking about this novel that captures the perspective of a kid like this so beautifully. The book is called Fight Night by Miriam Toews. The narrator is a nine-year-old named Swiv. Swiv lives with her mom and her grandma.
我一直想起这本小说，它如此优美地捕捉到了这样一个孩子的视角。书名是《Fight Night》，作者是Miriam Toews。叙述者是一个叫Swiv的九岁女孩。Swiv和她的妈妈以及奶奶住在一起。
Her grandma is wild, fun, and weird. The grandma homeschools Swiv, and her lessons are things like how to dig a winter grave, and let's analyze our dreams. The grandma is also sick, so Swiv helps her bathe, keeps track of her medications for her and the tiny batteries for her hearing aids.
她奶奶狂野、有趣又古怪。奶奶在家教育Swiv，教的内容是比如如何挖一个冬天的坟墓，让我们分析一下梦境。奶奶也病了，所以Swiv帮她洗澡，帮她记录药物剂量，以及她助听器的小电池。
She also helps her grandma cut up her favorite mystery novels into smaller sections. Because the grandma likes to take thin pieces of her books with her when she goes out. Swiv's mom is a working actor, struggling to get jobs. She's pregnant and seems to be suffering a mental health crisis. As Swiv says, sometimes, quote, "Mom goes scorched-earth."
她还帮奶奶把自己最喜欢的悬疑小说剪成小段。因为奶奶出门时喜欢带上书里薄薄的一部分。Swiv的妈妈是一位在职演员，为找工作挣扎。她怀孕了，看起来患有心理健康危机。正如Swiv所说，有时，引述，“妈妈会焦土化”。
It's rare to see these particular adults through the lens of a nine-year-old. And she's such a nine-year-old. She's both naive and knowing. Swiv is constantly interpreting these two women.
通过九岁孩子的镜头观察这些特定的成年人是很少见的。她确实是个九岁孩子。她既天真又懂行。Swiv不断地解读这两个女人。
She speaks the way they speak. She believes what they believe. But then, she's not sure. A lot of the book is her reacting to them, figuring out what they have under control, and what she, Swiv, will need to take care of herself, including the baby coming.
她说着她们的话。她相信她们相信的东西。但后来，她又不确定。书的很大一部分是她对她们的反应，弄清楚她们有哪些是在掌控之中的，哪些是Swiv自己需要去照料的，包括即将到来的婴儿。
Swiv calls the baby in her mom's belly "Gord," and she's often warning Gord about these crazy adults and how she'll have to prepare him. My favorite parts of the book are when Swiv is out in the world with her grandma and her mom, and you see how much she is constantly anticipating their behavior and trying, in her very kid way, to manage them. And so here's an excerpt from Fight Night.
Swiv把妈妈肚子里的婴儿叫“Gord”，她经常警告Gord关于这些疯狂的成年人的事，以及她将如何不得不为他做好准备。书中我最喜欢的部分是Swiv和奶奶以及妈妈在外面闯荡时，你看到她是多么不断地在预测她们的行为，并试图以她孩子的方式去管理她们。这是一段《Fight Night》的节选。
"Today was Thursday, and Grandma and I went to Scarborough for her body work. And I did all our laundry for the trip to Fresno and went to Shoppers for Grandma's meds. On the way to Scarborough, Mom rode on the bus with us for four blocks and got mad at three men for not letting her or Grandma sit on the bench for old and pregnant people.
“今天是周四，我和奶奶去了斯卡伯勒进行身体治疗。我做了我们去弗雷斯诺旅行的所有洗衣工作，并去了Shoppers买奶奶的药。在去斯卡伯勒的路上，妈妈和我们一起乘了四站公交车，并对三个没让妈妈或奶奶坐在老人和孕妇长椅上的男人发了火。
I had already found another seat for Grandma, and Mom didn't really look very pregnant with her giant Inspector Gadget coat on. So how were those men supposed to know? But naturally, Mom got mad anyway and said, excuse me, but these seats aren't meant for you.
我已经给奶奶找到了另一个座位，而且妈妈穿着巨大的Inspector Gadget外套，看起来并不太像个孕妇。所以那些男人怎么会知道呢？但自然，妈妈还是生气了，说，对不起，这些座位不是为你们准备的。
The men were all deaf, or they didn't want to answer her. And they just stared at their phones or into space. Mom said she was pregnant and her mother was elderly, so could the men give them their seats. One of the guys said congratulations but didn't move.
那些男人要么耳聋，要么不想回答她。他们只是盯着手机或虚空。妈妈说她是孕妇，她母亲是老人，所以男人们能不能把座位让给她们。其中一个家伙说了恭喜，但没动。
Then Grandma hollered at Mom from the front of the bus and said, honey, it's fine. Swiv found me a seat. Plus, Mom was getting off in five seconds at the theater. So why would she even want to sit down, and then leap up again right away?
然后奶奶在公交车前部对着妈妈大喊，说，亲爱的，没关系。Swiv给我找到了座位。加上妈妈五秒后就要在剧院下车了。所以她为什么要坐下来，然后又立刻跳起来呢？
Mom said, OK, but that's not really the point. And then, she stopped talking and stood there silently, like a normal person, which was such a relief that I almost started crying. But then, no, she couldn't bear to be normal for more than four seconds, and she said to the woman standing next to her that this kind of thing made her mental.
妈妈说，好吧，但那不是重点。然后，她停止了说话，像个正常人一样静静地站在那里，这让我感到如释重负，差点哭出来。但后来，不，她无法忍受正常超过四秒，她对站在她旁边的女人说，这种事情让她抓狂。
And I wanted to tell the woman standing next to her that every kind of thing made Mom mental, and do not respond. Grandma didn't hear anything, and just sat happily beside me reading one of her Dead Heat sections. I noticed a teenager looking at Grandma's sawed-up book. and the teenager saw me looking at her, and then looked away. My family should never be out in the world.
我想告诉站在她旁边的那个女人，每一件事情都让妈妈抓狂，千万别回应。奶奶什么都没听见，只是高兴地坐在我旁边读她的一段《Dead Heat》。我注意到一个十几岁的女孩在看奶奶锯开的书。那个女孩看到我在看她，然后转过脸去。我的家人就不该出现在外面。
The woman standing next to Mom said, I know, right? I lose my shit. Mom had found a crazy friend. I looked out the window and saw the theater where Mom rehearses and turned around to look at Mom and beg her with my eyes to get off the bus now, but without saying goodbye to me and without drawing any attention whatsoever to the fact that we know each other.
站在妈妈旁边的女人说，我知道，对吧？我也会疯。妈妈交到了一个疯狂的朋友。我看向窗外，看到了妈妈排练的剧院，转过身看妈妈，用眼神乞求她现在下车，但不要跟我说再见，不要引起任何我们认识对方的注意。
Oh, said Mom, my stop. Bye, honey, she said, don't forget to cross at the lights with Grandma, which made it sound like I was a stupid little kid who didn't know how to even live, when Grandma was the one who was hellbent for leather and wanted to jaywalk, but was too slow and distracted to dodge the cars properly and would almost get killed every time.
哦，妈妈说，我的站到了。再见，亲爱的，她说，别忘了和奶奶一起过马路，这听起来好像我是个连生活都不会的愚蠢小孩子，奶奶才是那个不知死活、想闯红灯，但又太慢、太分心没法躲过汽车，每次都差点被撞死的人。
Mom pushed herself and Gord through the people standing in the aisle, and bent down to give me and Grandma kisses, and then had to shout at the bus driver, who was closing the door. Wait, wait! This is my stop! The driver opened the door again and shook his head. And Mom said, bye, guys, bye, honey, in a loud voice, waving directly at me, and then finally got off the fucking bus.
妈妈挤过站在过道上的人群，俯身亲吻了我和奶奶，然后不得不对正在关门的公交车司机大喊。等一下，等一下！这是我的站！司机再次打开门，摇了摇头。妈妈大声说，再见大家，再见亲爱的，直接朝我挥手，然后终于下了该死的公交车。
My face hurt. I tried to drop my shoulders and read Dead Heat along with Grandma to take my mind off being the daughter of the world's most unstable person. Then the lady Mom had made friends with was suddenly standing beside me and said in an even louder voice than Mom, oh, man, your mom is awesome.
我的脸好痛。我试图放松肩膀，和奶奶一起读《Dead Heat》，好把心思从身为世界上最不稳定的人的女儿这件事上移开。然后妈妈交到的那个女士突然站在我旁边，用比妈妈更大的声音说，天哪，你妈妈真棒。
She said it so loud, that even Grandma heard her. And she said, she is indeed. She's my daughter. One of the guys who hadn't given Mom his seat heard it, too, and said Mom was a crazy bitch. Mom's new friend said, she's not a crazy bitch. You're a crazy bitch.
她说得那么大声，连奶奶都听到了。她说，她确实棒。她是我女儿。其中一个没让座的家伙也听到了，说妈妈是个疯狂的泼妇。妈妈的新朋友说，她不是疯狂的泼妇。你才是疯狂的泼妇。
The other two men who wouldn't give up their seats started laughing. Then Mom's new friend said to Grandma, oh, wow, you guys are three generations, which was like an obvious thing, not an oh-wow thing. One of the guys said, suck it, bitch.
另外两个没让座的家伙开始笑。然后妈妈的新朋友对奶奶说，哦，哇，你们是三代人，这就像一件显而易见的事，而不是一件“哦，哇”的事。其中一个家伙说，去死吧，泼妇。
Grandma said, that we are, aren't I lucky? Mom's new friend said, fuck you, you fucking piece of shit. The bus driver looked at everyone in his rearview mirror and said they had to behave themselves or get off the bus.
奶奶说，我们确实是，我难道不幸运吗？妈妈的新朋友说，去你的，你这坨狗屎。公交车司机看着后视镜里的每个人，说他们必须规矩点，否则就下车。
The lady talked away in her loud voice about wishing she could come home with us and be in our family. I had to do something. I couldn't slice my head off by slamming the window on it, because they were sealed up to keep children safe. I stood up and said, oh, Grandma, this is our stop. Come on.
那位女士用她的大嗓门滔滔不绝地说着希望她能和我们一起回家，成为我们家庭的一员。我必须做点什么。我没法通过关窗夹掉自己的头，因为窗户是为了保护儿童而被封死的。我站起来说，哦，奶奶，这是我们的站。快走吧。
Grandma said, what, we're nowhere near Scarborough. I said, I know, but first, we had to stop at this other place called-- I quickly looked out the window-- For Your Eyes Only. Grandma looked out the window.
奶奶说，什么，我们离斯卡伯勒还远着呢。我说，我知道，但首先，我们得在这个叫……的地方停一下——我迅速看了一眼窗外——《For Your Eyes Only》。奶奶看向窗外。
What do you want with a gentleman's club, Swiv, she said. She started laughing with Mom's new friend. I pulled Grandma up from her seat and stuffed her book section into my backpack. Because it's where we're going, I said. Bye, I said to the lady. I whispered it.
Swiv，你去绅士俱乐部干什么，她说。她开始和妈妈的新朋友大笑。我把奶奶从座位上拉起来，把她的书段塞进背包里。因为这就是我们要去的地方，我说。再见，我对那位女士说。我低声说。
OK, said Grandma. She shrugged. Looks like we've got an interesting itinerary. I pulled Grandma off the bus without saying thank you to the driver. Mom can't stand it when people say thank you to the driver when they get out at their stop. But Grandma thinks it's a decent thing to do.
好的，奶奶说。她耸耸肩。看来我们有一个有趣的行程。我把奶奶拽下公交车，没对司机说谢谢。妈妈最受不了人们下车时对司机说谢谢。但奶奶认为那是有礼貌的做法。
She told Mom that people clap and applaud when Mom does her job of acting. So why shouldn't people clap for pilots when they land the plane or say thank you, at least, to a bus driver? Mom said applause seemed sarcastic and bizarre. She hates applause, even for herself. And Grandma asked her how the audience is supposed to express their gratitude for her performance. And Mom said, just by sitting there quietly.
她告诉妈妈，人们在妈妈演戏时会鼓掌。那为什么人们在飞行员降落飞机时不能鼓掌，或者至少对公交车司机说声谢谢呢？妈妈说掌声看起来既讽刺又怪异。她讨厌掌声，即使是给自己的。奶奶问她观众该如何表达对她表演的感激。妈妈说，只要静静地坐在那儿就行。
Grandma said thank you to the bus driver, and he nodded very slowly. My pleasure, he said, enjoy your day. Grandma wanted to say more about her day, but I pulled and pulled on her arm. And the driver shut the door, and we were finally alone on the sidewalk.
奶奶对公交车司机说了声谢谢，他很慢地点了点头。我的荣幸，他说，祝你今天愉快。奶奶还想多说点关于她今天的事，但我拉了拉她的胳膊。司机关上了门，我们终于孤单地站在人行道上。
Grandma read the sign more closely. And then she stood back and looked at the giant pictures of naked women and started laughing her ass off again, because I, of all people, had wanted to get out at a strip club. She had to lean against the building, right against one of the pictures of the naked ladies, to catch her breath. I walked away down the sidewalk, so nobody would see me standing outside For Your Eyes Only, and left Grandma there struggling all by herself to live.
奶奶更仔细地看了看那个牌子。然后她退后一步，看着那些巨大的裸女图片，又笑得前仰后合，因为我，竟然想在一个脱衣舞俱乐部下车。她不得不靠在建筑物上，紧挨着其中一张裸女图片，以喘口气。我沿着人行道走开，免得有人看到我站在《For Your Eyes Only》外面，把奶奶一个人留在那里艰难地活着。
She finally finished getting her breath back, and I said, come on, Grandma, let's go. I mean it. And then, believe it or not, she posed on the sidewalk in the same position as the naked lady in the picture, with her knees bent a bit, and her butt poking out, and her hands on her boobs.
她终于喘过气来，我说，快走吧，奶奶，我们走。我说真的。然后，你信不信，她在人行道上摆出了和图片里裸女一样的姿势，膝盖微弯，屁股撅着，双手放在胸部。
I looked down at the sidewalk for things to kill myself with. There was nothing but globs of spit, and cigarette butts, and a flyer about the end of the world. And then, Grandma was beside me. And she took my arm, laughing, and said, ooh, boy! Where to next?
我低头看向人行道，寻找能让我自杀的东西。除了口水团、烟蒂和一张关于世界末日的传单，什么都没有。然后，奶奶来到我身边。她挽住我的胳膊，大笑着说，喔，孩子！下一步去哪？
That's from the book Fight Night by Miriam Toews. The audio you heard was excerpted from the official audiobook, which is narrated by the author and Georgia Toews and came to us, courtesy of Recorded Books.
这是Miriam Toews所著的《Fight Night》。你听到的音频节选自官方有声书，由作者和Georgia Toews本人朗诵，由Recorded Books提供。
Our program was produced today by me and edited by Emanuele Berry. The people who put together today's show include James Bennett II, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Bethel Habte, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由我和Emanuele Berry共同制作和编辑。今天参与制作的人员包括James Bennett II、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Bethel Habte、Cassie Howley、Valerie Kipnis、Seth Lind、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Alissa Shipp、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Abraham Oleksnianski, Marianne McCune, Jessica Mendoza, Brooke Yarbrough, Juan "Punchy" Gonzalez, Paige Duggins-Clay, Erin Einhorn, David Riedman, Amy Klinger, Andrew Hairston, Russell Skiba, and Alaa Mustafa. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free.
我们的总编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢Abraham Oleksnianski、Marianne McCune、Jessica Mendoza、Brooke Yarbrough、Juan "Punchy" Gonzalez、Paige Duggins-Clay、Erin Einhorn、David Riedman、Amy Klinger、Andrew Hairston、Russell Skiba和Alaa Mustafa。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过700期的存档。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. Did you guys know that Ira's known me since I was a baby? I asked him recently if he knew way back when that one day, I would host his radio show. He said he was sure it would never happen.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我的老板Ira Glass。你们知道吗，Ira从我婴儿时期就认识我了。我最近问他，他当年是否知道有一天我会主持他的广播节目。他说他确信那绝不会发生。
Like, even though, as a baby, I knew you were a flawed person, I just didn't expect that from you.
就像，尽管作为一个婴儿时我就知道你有瑕疵，但我确实没想到你会那样。
Well, here I am. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
好吧，我在这儿。我是Chana Joffe-Walt。Ira下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。